so this video that I'm going to show you
is truly genuinely delightful it is some
old fashioned face planting and it all
happened on Fox News
you probably heard by now Donald Trump's
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma where he
expected 60,000 people for which they
believed they received a million ticket
requests they had 6,200 people show up
according to the fire department so
here's video of two different Trump
tools who went on Fox News who had no
way to explain what happened other than
to completely collapse and it's just a
pleasure to watch this is total
schadenfreude and I completely admit it
it is taking pleasure in the failure of
others but it is pleasure for the
greater good
if 19,000 people had shown up if 62,000
people had shown up it would have been a
disaster in terms of coronavirus spread
we should all be glad from a public
health perspective that only 6,200
people showed up so here's the first
video this is Mercedes slap a Trump
campaign
senior advisor watch and enjoy campaign
said that more than a million people
wanted tickets for this rally but we all
saw the pictures last night the the
arena was no more than two-thirds full
and the outdoor rally that had been
planned for the overflow crowd was
canceled because there was no overflow
crowd question what happened well first
of all thank you for having me Chris and
happy Father's Day to you for let me
explain when it comes to understanding
how the rallies work it's a first come
first serve basis basically what the 1
million RSVPs include it's an
opportunity for us to gather data to get
information and obviously so the key
here is that some that is important is
to understand then I had this with my
own personal family who lives not far
away from Tulsa that they were concerned
there were factors involved like they
were concerned about the protesters who
were coming in there were protesters who
blocked the bags and so we saw that have
an impact in terms of people coming to
the rally but what was amazing
Chris was the fact that over 5.3 million
people watched it on all of our digital
media channels and so the reach was far
and wide and that doesn't even include
the TV numbers we also did a pre rally
show and that was a over 2 million views
so you know we're living in a virtual
time as well Sadie's Mercedes effect
Mercedes if I can yes the fact is the
president talks about the attendance at
his events as we all know it would he
made a big issue of the attendance at
his inauguration he talks about how he
can fill out an arena and that Joe Biden
can't
he didn't fill an arena last night and
so far off let me if I may finish and
you guys were so far off that you had
planned an outdoor rally and there
wasn't an overflow crowd and I have
watching the coverage and talking to
Marc Meredith on the ground today
protesters did not stop people from
coming to that rally the fact is
absolutely they didn't tell you there
were people I'm telling you there were
people and families that didn't want to
bring their children because of concerns
of the protesters oh it was first-come
first-served so then it wasn't a
completely embarrassing failure so you
know again with the protesters silly
liberal snowflakes
apparently scared off these rugged
conservatives from seeing their Lord and
Savior in person doesn't sound like the
Alpha behavior that they claim to
exhibit does it that that's your best
argument so now the issue isn't so much
how many went but she makes it about how
many people watched and of course a ton
of people were watching for the comedic
and dystopian elements there were a ton
of streams from the left ridiculing the
entire thing and again to believe that
if a million people wanted to go and
only 6200 showed up we're supposed to
believe that ninety nine point four
percent of the people that wanted to go
were scared off by liberals what a
pathetic argument to be making and then
you might have noticed that she went
into attacking Biden saying look Biden's
not bringing huge crowds Biden isn't
doing any big events Biden doesn't
claim that he's never had an empty seat
at every event that he does Biden is
being responsible in the context of the
corona Spira corona virus pandemic
because some statistically people are
going to die because of that rally the
rally was held there will be some
contagion that happens that otherwise
wouldn't and some fraction of those
people are going to die fortunately it
will be fewer than if there had been
19,000 or 62,000 people there just
hilarious and then here's another one
named Jenna Ellis she's a senior legal
adviser to the Trump 2020 campaign she
says thousands of people were turned
away which is sort of neither here nor
there but what I love in this clip is
she says look thousands of people turned
out for hours earlier they were talking
about a million ticket requests and now
she's bragging that thousands showed up
take a look not at all this was a
wonderful attendance and we're so proud
of all of the great American patriots
who showed up in thousands to support
the president in his first rally in over
three months and listen the fact that
there were so many obstacles to overcome
to even get into the BOK center there
and still we had over 6,000 people plus
thousands more outside that were turned
away this was an incredibly strong event
and I think it this is the most
hilarious goal post move that I've maybe
ever seen a million people supposedly
requested tickets we had thousands of
people show up that's a huge huge
success what a victory you got trolled
including by what it seems were just
teenagers requesting tickets on the
Internet you would almost feel bad for
these people
for looking so dumb on national
television and then you remember they're
choosing to show up and be interviewed
and defend this total failure they're
choosing to work with the re-election
campaign of Donald Trump and this gets
us back to an important reminder rally
crowds don't win elections whether Trump
had sixty two hundred or six hundred and
twenty or sixty two thousand or six
hundred and twenty thousand people show
up rally crowds don't win elections if
rally crowds won elections Bernie
Sanders would currently be the
Democratic nominee
there's one race that matters and it's
how many people vote in November and
you've got to do it figure out what's
going on with vote by mail and absentee
figure out which polling places are
being closed down we'll talk about that
in the context of Kentucky's primary
election tomorrow figure it all out
because that's really the only thing
that matters make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show we now have a video
that is going viral it's going altra
viral of me making a meal that I grew
from scratch in my backyard okay
everything that I eat in this meal it's
this is kind of a joke but you've got to
look at it for yourself I grew myself in
my backyard harvested prepared myself
okay that's david pakman show on
instagram don't miss it let me know what
you think if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink Aslam kissed lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video